اذا كنت تعرف الرقم الفرعي ادخله الان
الفنانين احييكم اجمل تحيه وادعوكم لسماع
باقه جديده من اغنيتكم نرجو محاوله
الاتصال في وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
هنا مكه
بين جبالها يتردد صدى تاريخ مجيد وحاضر
مشرق فلكل وجهه قصه وحكايه
ومكانه ومكانه في وجدان المسلمين
فعلى قمه هذا الجبل الاشم حراء
كانت البدايه
والرساله الخاتمه
وانا اسعد خليفه انا صوت عمر بن الخطاب في
المسلسل وحتى بعد تجربتهم عمرا كتبت شعرا
يعني اختصرت الشخصيه بالكامل في بيت شعر
واحد عندما قلت دخلت الحروب طويت الخطوب
ابيت نازلا بموضع مغلوب اتاني الهبوب بقدر
مكتوب قضيت خاشعا بخنجر مضروب
[موسيقى]
ليست هيبه الحكم في ترويع الناس
ولكن في تامينهم مسلسل عمر كامل محطه مهمه
جدا في مسيرتي ككل
وسبحان الله يعني عمر شخصيته واللي صار
بالمسلسل اللي هو هذا كسر لتابوهات كان ما
حدا يقرب عليها يعني اولا فكره انه الجسدي
عمر بالكاميرا بالصوت والصوره هذا ما كان
يصير اثنين
انه ينعمل دوبلاج من عربي لعربي برضو اول
مره هاي بتصير
ما انزلنا عليك القران لتشقى
الا تذكره لمن يخشى
تنزيلا ممن خلق الارض
والسماوات العلا
الرحمن على العرش استوى اسلام عمر انا لما
عملته يعني تقريبا هو الاكثر تاثيرا في
الناس والاكثر طلبا انه يشاف مره تانيه
انا هذا المشهد بالذات وهذه الحادثه اللي
حملها عمر بن الخطاب مع اخته انا بالنسبه
لي تعاملت معها باقصى ما اعرف من فنون
التمثيل والتنسيد الشخصيه
قد سلم في الاسلام ظلمه لا ترتق
كان والله سدادا لنحور العدو الاشياء اللي
فيها مشاعر هاي انا بتصور معظم اللي
عملتهم ما كان ردود افعاله كويسه
يعني ما يؤثر بالمجتمع
وبحسه انه عمل عنده شيء اكيد انا بتاثر
فيه كمان لدرجه انه بصير عندي سلوك يعني
العباره المشهوره لسيدنا عمر رضي الله عنه
لما كان يقول في الاخر قضي الامر خلاص ما
في رجعه فصرت احيانا انا اتورط فيها اتفرط
فيها ايجابيا
يا عمرو
متى استعبدتم الناس وقد ولدتهم امهاتهم
احرار
قضي الامر
الاستوديو
كونه تعودت عليه يعني عايش مع الميكروفون
وعايش مع الجاليري وعايش مع التقنيات
وبحاول دائما انه عايش الحاضره واقي
بالمستقبل حتى بهذه الاشياء اعطتني اشياء
كتير من اجمل ما اعطتني اياه انا لو بدي
احسبها حسبي حسابيه كميه الزمن او الكلام
اللي تكلمته باللغه العربيه الفصيحه يعني
ممكن 90% من حياه الطبيعيه لانه معظم وقتي
بالاستديو
يا رجال
تماسكوا الشخصيه اللي انا عملتها بفيلم
بلال مش بلال انا عملت حمزه بن عبد المطلب
رضي الله عنه العالم بره اصبح الان ينظر
الى الشخصيه من خلال الملهم من الهم ان
يكون هكذا فكان الملهم لبلال بن رباح
سيدنا حمزه بن عبد المطلب انا عملت سيدنا
حمزه وكان جد بالفعل جدا شخصيه صعبه جدا
لانه هي هي اللي رسمت بلال
[موسيقى]
اذكر انه باسبانيا انا كنت رايح ادرس طب
زي اي طالب عادي في ساحه في وسط مدريد
اسمها بلاته اسبانيا المكان جميل ونحن
بشباب صغار يعني بحب يطلع صوته اما بلحن
اما بنغمه
في شخص اسباني مره بقول لي شو رايك تعمل
معاي دعايه بقول انا اعمل دعايه بالاسباني
بعرفش كويس قال لي كلمه كلمه واحده قلت له
كلمه مقدور عليها فطلب مني احكي كلمه لها
علاقه بالمطابخ كوثينيرو الكلمه بالضبط
كان رحت معه على الاستوديو سجلتها طبعا
فيها لعب طبقات صوت واداله لان الكلمه
طويله
فيها مجال تعمل اشياء كثيره فسجلتها
وعجبته
يمكن للصوت ان يكون مرئيا يعني انا لما
بحكي وبخاطب اذنك عادي بس تخيل احكي
واخاطب عينك اخاطب حاسه اخرى انه اللي
بحكيه تشوفه مش فقط تسمعه
[موسيقى]
من الاشياء كثير اللي ما زال صداها موجوده
عند الناس في برنامج ال البيت ايامها انا
يعني اخترت اشاره الصوتيه كانت من ابيات
للامام الشافعي وكنا نقول فيها يا ال بيت
رسول الله حبكم فرض من الله في القران
انزله يكفيكم من عظيم الفخر انكم من لم
يصلي عليكم لا صلاه له يا ال بيت رسول
الله
[موسيقى]
فرض من الله في القران
انجازات مع التلفزيون الوطني شاركنا في
برنامج عن الخط العربي وكنا فريق
[موسيقى]
ما بعرف اعيش من دون صوت طير وقال لي
الطير بالفعل هذا اكثر شيء انا بالنسبه لي
بحكيها على لسان الطير حتى بثقافتنا
العربيه فلان قال على لسان فلان وليس فقط
على الانسان الطيب
[موسيقى]
كما اقول على لسان الطير الا انني لقولك
فاهم
اليوم هو الاول من عمرنا القادم
اذا كنت لا تسمع صمتي فانت لا تعرف صوتي
[موسيقى]